now someone sent me this video so i cho
so
about a week not today but about a week
ago talk about this whole point of
selling your souls
i sold my soul
so you got these island boys
yes i'm saying
and one of the brothers he came out on
live stream
someone shared this with me and asked me
to comment on it about selling his soul
and uh ever since i sold my soul so
let's go ahead and watch what he had to
say and then come back and give our
thoughts on this i'm gonna elucidate on
it explain it with some clarity can you
really sell your soul
and what does that actually mean so
let's go ahead and watch this and then
we'll get some clarity on it and uh ever
since i sold my soul i haven't been
happy ever since
you know what i'm saying
um
y'all ain't gotta believe me anywhere it
is i i s like i'm not even capping
it's because listen i had to do it you
know i'm saying because like
i had to do it because i was trying to
make it like you feel me
like
and as if when i was like setting my
soul
um
like there was things that i could
sacrifice about and stuff like that and
i sacrificed myself you really got to
pick you wanted something saying and and
and and
and you get anything you want you get to
be rich
you get to you get to be you get to have
fortune you get to you have to have
everything everything you ever wanted
you feel me but you could think i'm cat
i'm not tripping
i did it a week ago
i haven't been happy ever since
i'm having anxiety
every single day
what did i wish for
to be famous
and be rich
all right so the question is you hear
him saying he sold his soul can you
actually sell your soul like you sell a
car like you sell a house
no you can't sell your soul
that soul is going to go back to the
creator of the heavens and earth we all
have a soul and the soul
is
here with us it's going to leave us and
the body is going to stay behind and
some souls are going to come out
peacefully to go back
like we have i mean this is so beautiful
in islam we have all the details of what
happens to the soul so i really
encourage these young
island boys and those followers of
theirs to really take the matter really
serious because this is a serious issue
now you can go ahead and make a pact and
this is what he probably did now we see
this all the time we see these musicians
we see the lady gagas you know the
beyonce's you know all of these famous
hip-hop stars rock stars
they come out and they say they made
some
pact with the devil or they sold their
soul so this is what it actually i mean
it's not yours that you can go ahead and
sell it
but you can go ahead and commit what's
called shirk so this is what they did
this is this is the actual technical
term it's making a pact so they make a
pact
instead of seeking help from the creator
of the heavens and the earth from god
almighty allah they start to seek help
from the satanic forces from iblees from
the shayateen from these dark forces and
this is real this is something that the
quran talks about this unseen world so
when a human being goes and commits
shirk this is the worst thing that you
can do because a person will be crippled
they'll think okay i sold my soul like
if you sold your car your house and
that's it if you sold it it's gone and
if the other person has the title you
can't get it back but in this case this
is something that now
when you understand you cannot sell your
soul and you can go ahead and redeem
yourself you can go ahead and change
your ways you can go ahead and turn back
because the person who made the pact
with the devil they have to do some
disgusting despicable things
to go ahead and seek help from iblees
from the shiatine from these dark forces
from these devils
and what happens then from there life as
you see him testifying life doesn't get
better it always gets worse i did it a
week ago
i haven't been happy ever since
the depression the anxiety all of these
things start to kick in and then the
shayateen these devils ask you to the
next level they'll go ahead and want
things from you to go ahead and do more
dirty and disgusting things but on the
flip side when someone seeks help from
their creator
from god almighty allah life seems to
get better it always does yes you'll
have hard times trials tribulations yes
but you get the serenity peace and
contentment
and you at the end you get the reward
for all your struggles with paradise but
if a person goes down that route of
making a pact with the devil worshiping
the devil shaytan iblees going down that
route what happens then the hellfire is
the final destination so let me go ahead
and share with you some a few passages
from the verbatim word of god almighty
uh allah the quran and i got some good
news really good news at the end god
almighty allah is saying in chapter 3
verse 53 the quran sailed my servants
who have transgressed
against their own souls so what kind of
transgression is this this is the
optimal transgression the worst
transgression you could do against your
soul is to go ahead and give it that
you're literally you're trying to sell
it off to these dark forces to the
shayateen to these devils so now what
happens is god almighty is telling you
those who have transgressed so even if
you transgressed against your own soul
despair night of the mercy of allah the
creator despair not allah forgives all
sin so even if you you've done something
horrific like this something very evil
don't worry island boy don't worry all
of the fan boys of island boy and people
who have
gone down the similar route
you still
have a chance while you're alive to go
and make it right so god almighty allah
is saying indeed
allah forgives all sins truly he is the
most forgiving the most merciful so
remember that now on the flip side there
are also verses in the quran that talk
about if the person continues
going down this route
of
worshipping
other than the crater that heavens and
earth
then a person will find his a final boat
in the hellfire and then the soul what
we're talking about the soul for the
person who has dedicated his life who's
changed his life he could have been like
you know doing all sorts of things all
corrupt things and then at the end that
person turns their life around repents
turns to the crater alone the one
god that jesus worship that moses
worship this is the one creator that
prophet muhammed called mankind to
worship as he's the last and final
messenger sent to mankind
then
that person when it's time for that soul
to leave the body then it will come out
imagine there's a description prophet
muhammad peace and blessed be upon him
is giving us a description in the hadith
that like a vessel pouring water imagine
the the water coming out of a vessel
nice and smooth that's how the soul when
the time of death comes out it's going
to come out of the body nice and smooth
now a person who sold his soul to the
devil and we addressed that earlier
about selling your soul but the person
who committed shirk who has gone down
the rebellious route
who follows the footsteps of shaytan who
submits not to his creator but to the
will of the devils the shayateen that
submits his or herself and lives a life
a rebellious life
doesn't take heed to the science this is
a sign now right but a person
wants to be idolized chases fame
to be famous
you know it doesn't care just
heedlessness living the life of
debauchery doesn't care about
really defining what the true purpose of
life is why am i here why have i been
created this worries about living an
ostentatious life about money cars women
you know and going to the clubs and
popping the bottles and drinking and
drugs and alcohol and then dies in that
state of making that pact selling his
soul like he said then what happens that
soul imagine some wool and then imagine
some hooks trying to pull through that
wool and it coming out getting stuck in
between and you got remnants of it
that's how the soul is going to be
extracted the bad soul will be extracted
from the body it will be tormented and
pulled out it's a very scary scenario
and that's why we're doing this out of
the love because we want to help prevent
that island boy and the rest of those
out there you have a chance to turn your
life back around
okay he didn't take no physical title
from you you didn't sell nothing but you
have
a way now to [ __ ] yourself
and now to stay in that place of
darkness and continue to go ahead and
benefit from that what's the benefit
nothing but anxiety stress depression
you can have all the money
and go on all the rides but you'll still
be empty and void inside or you can be
fulfilled and you can have fulfillment
in the heart that void will be
filled that money can't buy and you will
have peace and serenity and life in
paradise in the next life and you avoid
the hellfire and start after me you
start saying
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator allah and you start asking
for guidance from your creator and you
know what for everybody out there we
also have a free copy of the quran that
you can get at our website
thedeenshow.com go to the dean show.com
get a free copy of the quran where you
can learn more about the soul and the
topic of the devil the shaitaan's you
can learn more about how to worship your
creator what the purpose of life is it's
all in this quran everything is there
get a free copy and help get this
message like if you haven't subscribed
so we can go ahead and get this message
to the island boy and hopefully save him
god almighty can save him that he can go
ahead and get on the straight way the
right way we'll see you next time peace
be with you assalamu alaikum